Today's wild flowers are Charvi, Jessica
and Angelina from Dallas, Texas.
These girls made headlines when they came up
with a virtual tutoring program called TutorScope.
The nonprofit helps kids and their parents keep up
with the schoolwork during the pandemic.
I'd love to welcome them.
Charvi, Jessica, Angelina, are you there?
(audience cheering)
Hello.
Hi.
Okay, tell us about TutorScope.
So we started TutorScope back in March of 2020,
when the pandemic was starting
and schools were beginning to go virtual.
And with that, it became apparent
that student to teacher interactions would be affected,
because you can't really just walk up
to a teacher's desk to ask them a question
in a virtual setting.
So I thought, what if we could have student
tutors teaching other students virtually?
So I asked Angelina and Jessica to join me
and they were so excited, within two weeks
we had our entire website and system up and running
for students to actually start getting tutored.
And now we have over 22 tutors that are spread out all
across the United States, including Ohio, Texas
and even Arizona.
(audience cheering)
I mean, this is amazing.
I have to ask the next question, which is
do you think that the psychology
of also young people seeing other young people
because here's me in homeschool.
(laughing)
It literally, and my kids don't look at me like the teacher,
you know, I'm their parent.
And, you know, do you think that that am I
the only parent that feels this way?
Do kids feel this way?
Is there a kid adult dynamic?
What do you think?
There is definitely this component
of us being closer to the curriculum.
So kids are able to just like
kind of connect with us a little more.
It's just a very stressful right now for everyone.
And so we kind of also just help with the workload
and the stress that parents have right now.
And then also like decreasing the amount
of frustration that can be happening with like
having to become the teachers during this time.
Cause that's, that's just a new thing for a lot of parents.
Jessica, how do you feel about teaching kids?
You can do it in your own state
or other states can sign up to learn with you guys, right?
Yeah, exactly.
We'll tutor any kid,
no matter what city or state they're in.
And really, our main objective,
ever since we founded this organization,
was to have everything be completely
free of costs to the student.
So that has definitely allowed us
to be accessible to a lot of kids.
We've had about 250 students with us and, you know
over 500 have registered.
So, and they're all, you know
from elementary school to high school.
So it's been a really great experience.
And Angelina,
like what's next for your nonprofit?
Do you plan on expanding?
Everybody's like coming from even other countries?
What's the plan?
Yes of course, of course.
Well, like you already mentioned
we've actually been getting applications
from countries like Canada, India, or even Russia.
And we hope to continue creating a bigger impact
on a global scale to every child in need.
Angelina, do you ever see parents like me on the floor?
Like just flipped out?
Yeah I mean, we see, you know, firsthand parents
and everyone in general, they are just so stressed
because of all the changes that we have to go through.
So we hope to, you know
we re parents have that stress as well.
I can't thank you enough.
I mean, this is so hard.
This really is.
Do you feel like you are connecting
with these younger people
and really bringing like alleviation of all this stress?
Yeah, that's definitely what we're hoping to accomplish.
You know, I mean, as Angelina was saying
this pandemic has just brought on so many new changes
and stresses and what our goal is, is to kind
of just create that student to student interaction
that you'd normally get in school.
So, you know, before we study
for upcoming tests during lunch and things like that
so we just really kind of want to create that same dynamic
and same environment with TutorScope.
I can't thank you enough,
as a parent for all adults out there.
You know, I think that kids are gonna see you
and actually honestly behave themselves a little bit better,
and trust in the process a little bit more.
Thank you.
No.
Thank you actually.
And I just wanna donate $5,000
to you guys and your organization
and your company just to spend on whatever way you see fit
for the growth and development of the TutorScope program.
Because honestly
and I'm gonna match it with another 5,000.
So that's 10,000, to you guys.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you so much.
Oh my God, thank you so much.
You all deserve capes, you are so welcome.
You all deserve capes, go out there and fly and save us.
Thank you, Charvi, Jessica and Angelina,
TutorScope, visit our website
for more information
on how you can sign up for TutorScope.
(upbeat music)